- Well, thank you. So
nice to meet you, finally!
- Oh, finally? Okay, I'll take it.
So, I know you know Salma, right?
- Of course, yeah, yes.
(Salma kissing)
- (giggles) I was asking Salma, I'm like,
"Sometimes, when y'all
are in movies together,
you don't have scenes together,"
so I was like,
"Well," I was like, "Did y'all
meet?" And you did. (laughs)
- Yeah, but we had
a lot of fun together.
- Oh, yes.
- I love it, I'm so
excited about this film.
So, who was the most fun on set?
- I am sitting right next to her.
- Oh. (laughs)
- I have to say,
(audience clapping)
just so you know,
her middle name is P for party.
Party girl!
- Yes.
- She actually hosted this fab
Christmas party for everyone.
She actually cooked for everybody.
- You did? For everybody?
(audience cheering)
Usually people hire that out.
- And there's a lot of eternals huh?
It's a lot of people.
- [Kelly] That's what
I'm saying, that's a lot.
- But it was homey, we
made like a real Christmas.
Homey with friends and
relaxed and tequila.
(audience laughing)
- Okay,
I'll give you my number,
I like tequila food and fun.
- She likes the tequila.
- "Eternals," it's full of representation,
and we were talking about
that earlier. It's so cool.
So how did you feel about representation
in film and TV whenever you were a kid?
- Well, I have to say,
growing up as a little kid,
I really didn't see a lot of
myself on TV or the big screen,
it was more like just bits
and pieces here and there.
And I saw a deaf woman on
"Sesame Street," Linda Bove,
Linda the librarian, right?
(audience clapping)
I saw her and she was like me,
but another woman who really
inspired me was Frida Kahlo
and my mom at the time was a
grad student in art education
and she focused on Frida
and I just remember seeing this
beautiful, strong, talented,
Mexican woman who just claimed her space
in a world that was not ready
for a Mexican female artist.
And so it really inspired me.
(audience clapping)
- That's so cool.
Was that really important to
you when you played Frida?
- Yes.
I think we're similar in the fact that
what inspired me was her
courage to be unique,
which is very similar
to what she's saying.
And I think it's lovely that that woman,
that is no longer with us, in person,
inspired two girls, very
different, separately,
although, let me tell
you, she's half Mexican.
(Kelly laughing)
- That is right.
You really inspired me also
because this beautiful Mexican
woman who's also Lebanese
and half Mexican.
So I really looked to her and
how she actually represented
and revealed her identity
and her differences
and her different intersections.
- And the interesting thing,
(audience clapping)
while we were shooting, she
was a huge inspiration to me.
- Oh, that's so cool.
I love being inspired
by people I work with.
(audience clapping)
- I will take that with me forever.
- Yeah, so how did you find
out that you got the role?
- Well,
I remember it was Valentine's day
and I was driving actually to
get some pizza for my boys,
and then I got an email
and that's how I found out
I had to pull over and
I couldn't believe it.
I was gonna be a superhero.
- So cool.
- Me.
And waiting for somebody
to jump in and say, "Psych!
Just kidding."
- (laughs) Psych? (laughs)
So Lauren, could you tell
us about your character
in "Eternals?"
- Well, Makkari, you may
already know she's a speedster,
she's really fast, she's
traveled all over the world,
I don't even know how many times.
And she loves art, she
loves books and really,
she just loves those earth people.
- So do all of them not love earth people?
Is that what you're getting at? (laughs)
When she said, "Mmm."
- Some more than others.
- Some more than others. (laughs)
That's a day that ends
in, "Why?" In my world.